(clicking)
- Spend the extra money
to do something crazy
that everybody wants to take a photo with.
- Cool.
- That's a good idea.
- You see where I'm going?
This portion is, like, with me,
so I think this is when
you need to get selfish.
Like, you need to ask your question.
(upbeat music)
Hiring is destiny, firing is knowing.
Like, you gotta go fast.
That's how you get shit done,
that's when you figure stuff out.
This is the television and
the television is the radio.
For 4Ds, motherfuckers.
What's on your mind, what can I answer?
- [Attendee] How do you
make determinations on where
and how you spend your time?
Knowing how valuable and
how limited your time is.
- Oh that's, I'm really happy
you're asking this question
because if you can internalize
what I'm about to say,
you will not believe what
it's about to do for you.
The answer is the ability
not to judge myself.
By, you know how a lot of times,
there's a lot of people in,
there's a really dirty
secret in the strategy world
of, like, Bain and McKinsey where,
if you really get them drunk,
they admit that the actions
lead to the strategy,
not the other way around.
That's my answer to you.
How?
I make decisions.
And then I try to look at my
calendar of the week ahead
and see if any decisions
I made four weeks earlier
that made me think this
was a good use of time.
Am I able to lose something,
cut something down?
I'm extremely thoughtful about
cutting times in meetings.
So one of the things I think
that really make me
successful is understanding
a seven minute meeting is real
and not just making it
a 30 minute meeting.
But the real reason is
'cause I don't overthink it.
I'm operating my business, I'm in it.
How do I decide between going
to dinner with Kevin Hart
because I can,
and I wanna build top of the funnel brand.
Or do I go take a mid-level client
that I'm trying to build
a relationship with?
It's, you know, you ask
every normal person,
it seems like those aren't super close,
but I can touch the pulse
and be like I'm going
to L.A. four more times
in the next three months.
You know, the biggest
mistakes I make are the ones
of missed opportunities of the things,
by being crippled by opportunity.
When you actually level
that all up, my friend,
it really is liberating.
You will never even come close
to making the right decision.
I mean it.
You just don't know what
the alternative would be.
People think that there's a right answer.
You, as an operator of your business,
make the right call that
feels right at that moment
and just move.
And people spend all this time and money
on trying to think that
there's a proper answer.
I play on the extremes.
I spend as much time as
possible on the things
that are showing me the
most offense, right?
However you're doing
your customer acquisition
to get to get their hun-do
on a product like that,
like, whether it's Facebook,
whether it's brand,
whether it's, and then I
spend the amount of time
on my biggest vulnerability.
You know, putting my finger in the holes
to make sure the boat doesn't sink,
and building a bigger fucking boat.
And nothing in the middle.
And knowing that I'm making
that judgment at all times
and the second I get
new data a week later,
I might have to completely change
what I thought was right the week before.
It's also why I spend a ton
of time with my employees.
The reason I'm an HR-driven CEO is
if you really understand this,
both your biggest growth
and your biggest vulnerabilities
are actually your own team.
So I think it's a lack of,
it starts with the ability
not to over-judge yourself
because that is the liberator
of the model I just broke down for you.
- [Attendee] But even the items
that you may have scheduled
out four weeks in advance,
you still sit down the beginning
of that week to reevaluate?
- At our best, which I
don't do all the time,
my admins and I are doing some sort
of version of an audit on Friday.
- [Attendee] Okay.
Because yeah, you find
yourself in that paralysis of,
where, are you spending your time
on the most valuable activities?
- I don't think that way,
nobody, I mean, listen.
I'm in the mix for top busy people.
I'm in the conversation.
(attendees laughing)
You know, I go hard for 15 hours a day,
I do seven minute meetings, I'm
fucking in the conversation.
And I easily spend 25% of my day
on things that end up being dumb shit.
That is where the speed comes in.
Got it?
If I spend time looking
back on my calendar
for the last month, I'd
be devastatingly sad.
People judge themselves.
If you're an operator
and you're in the mix on your business,
you made the best decision you could
at that moment with the data that you had.
The end.
Is it, was it to go to a Kroger's meeting?
Or was it to go meet a supplier of milk
or to go meet an
influencer who was destined
to be the one that broke you out?
All three sounds great to me.
And they all could end up being right
or could end up being wrong.
My thing is if you go super fast
and go super hard and super efficient,
you might be able to do all three
if you're not spending half
your time judging yourself
if you're getting it right, got it?
- [Attendee] Great point.
- You see where I'm going?
- [Attendee] I do.
- You wouldn't be here,
maybe that's what you needed today, like,
you would have this whole day back.
Just even, in the mind,
there's no way I'd do this.
That's not how I learn.
Now you may learn this way,
but there's never a chance in hell
that I'd ever be at a 4Ds.
'Cause I learned from so much doing.
That's why my data is so clean,
it's why I'm an innovator.
It's why I'm fast,
it's why a lot of good
things happen for me
because I realize just the
doing is actually more efficient
than the thinking about it.
Somebody said something
really funny to me once.
And it was, like, the dig of this version
and it's a really funny conversation.
He was talking about
VaynerMedia at the time,
this was maybe five or six years ago.
He said, you know, Gary,
I gotta tell you, I love your company.
But I gotta take a little
bit of a knock on you.
He was trying to set it up.
I'm like, okay, what is it?
He goes, if I was sitting in this room
and you guys were standing outside
and I said, VaynerMedia,
I need you to sit right next to me.
I know you guys would do it.
He goes, where I think you need
to be more thoughtful, Gary, is,
I have a feeling though that you might run
through that glass panel and sit with us
when you could've just
opened the fucking door.
And I said, yeah, but
which one was cooler?
You know and so, the
answer to that is, like,
I think what, you know,
what that gentleman didn't understand
in his analogy as a
critique was he was trying
to have an intellectual
conversation about something that,
it's, all of our businesses
will be super fun
to talk about in a Harvard business study
or around a campfire in 40
years with our grandkids
when we can pontificate,
but we're operating right now.
That.
Got it?
- [Attendee] I do.
- It will work.
You can't imagine
how much mind time is
actually being wasted
if you're thinking about that question.
It's crippling, I mean it.
I've a lot of empathy for it
and I'm really, like, that's why,
you know, I don't normally
pause before my answer.
I was super pumped you ask that
because it's one of the
biggest answers I've got
in my repertoire.
And if I can come, you know,
'cause I'm a good communicator,
if this is the moment and
you get momentum on this,
you will fucking,
you will be back in here and
be like, it was just that.
I didn't realize how much
that was affecting me.
And that makes you that faster.
Then all of the sudden, you
can see where this goes, right?
All of a sudden, 'cause you
know you're doing this thing
that's foreign to you, fuck it,
Gary said, let me try this week.
All of a sudden, you're like, fuck,
but I wanna get this other thing,
now all of a sudden, that 30
minute meeting becomes 16.
All of a sudden, that
meeting you just canceled
and you just do it the next day.
You turn it into call
on the way to the air.
I'm the manifestation at this point
of being in my prime of
something I've now done
for 22 years.
Tomorrow I turn 44, so I'm right there.
22 years of not running a business,
and 22 years of now running
businesses completely always
and now I'm in, you know,
in this state where like,
(sighing) I feel really,
you know, unstoppable
because it's like, there's,
you're just at the extreme version of it.
It's like working out
everyday for 20 years.
You're at a different place,
I'm in a real crescendo
of, like, this model.
And it really works.
It's practical.
- You don't beat yourself
up over mistakes?
- No.
Because everyone else is doing it for me.
(attendees laughing)
You know what I mean?
We just can't.
You know, I really do think business
is much more like sport.
You know, it's really funny.
I used to always think that,
it always made sense that I liked both.
Now I hear things, back
to being in the prime,
you hear things of like
a quarterback saying,
you know, you just gotta
go to the next play.
I know I threw two picks in a row.
And he's right.
I'm like, you know you
still hear it as a fan
and be like, fuck you,
you fucking threw two picks, I'm pissed.
You know, like, I thought about,
now I'm like, that's exactly right.
Like, I can make seven bad,
as long as I don't put us out of business.
No really, I really, it's that binary.
It's a funny thing to say,
but to your point and to, like, mine,
as long as I don't put us out of business,
I'm like, yeah, like,
I hate that I made that call, you know?
I prefer not to.
I wish it didn't happen, but it did
and spending, I'm learned from it.
I don't need to, like, beat
myself up to learn from it.
I learned from it, I
understand that I over,
right, I over-leveraged
our ice cream business
to too much retail and
gave them too much leverage
and now when they kick
me out, I'm in trouble
and I should've built my
direct-to-consumer business.
- Right.
- Right?
It's not super complicated.
- [Ice Cream Attendee] Yeah.
- [Attendee] Then speed becomes your ally
when you're able to move.
- Bro and you'll love this.
- [Attendee] Yeah.
- One thing that business
and fuckin' sports share
that nobody talks about,
speed over everything.
There's a reason the
Chiefs are good right now.
They figured it out.
Draft speed.
It's not teachable.
- [Attendee] To your point
that you find often you're
in situations where you have to make that,
you have to make snap decisions.
I can choose to do this
or I can choose to do that
and you're only basing
it on the available data.
- Correct, I don't even
have to do any homework,
it's why I'm always improv.
I'm fucking operating my business,
I can make a decision right now.
It's the lack of judgment, right?
You see we're into that,
see how that's kinda
frothy but you're like,
oh right, that makes sense.
'Cause if you choose
and then it was super
obvious six months later
that you shoulda went
triple retail instead
of doing diet milk or you
know I'm making up shit now.
Well, well, okay, but like, I didn't,
but, like what?
Like, I don't think,
I think people think
they're gonna do some,
they value process.
When you're dealing with
the actual consumer,
they're moving as fast as you are.
- [Attendee] Faster.
- Not with me, that's why I win, right?
Like I feel like I'm with 'em.
I'm day trading.
My decisions are in day trade mode.
And people think that they're,
they over-value what they
were taught in school.
The process.
You know how many more
decisions you can make
when you're not in the process of one?
And then what ends up
happening is you net win.
Because that mistake you made was offset
by four other good decisions you made.
It's so cool to, like, even like,
like I'm listening to
myself almost right now
and I'm like, God, it
makes so much fucking sense
but it speaks to why
entrepreneurship is hard
and talent-oriented.
It is truly a skill, like,
there's a very big difference
between being an entrepreneur
and being an operator.
And some entrepreneurs can be operators
and they tend to do well.
And some people can be operators
and they build very nice businesses,
but getting good at those two things
and the entrepreneurial part is
where the real hyper
upside actually lives.
The operating part is commoditized.
It's a more teachable skill
than leaning into intuition,
leaning into listening
to the end consumer,
leaning into, you know,
nuances of the innovation.
Being, enjoying risk.
Not being fearful.
I think, I think that
what I just talked about
is being the Chiefs
and I think most people are
trying to build the '85 Bears.
People are defense-oriented,
which is great.
Both can be good, right?
In the way that I just said it, but like,
there are way more teams that have won
because they were the best offense.
Defense wins championships
is a very, very misleading,
very misleading statement.
- [Attendee] Hall of Fame
defensive linemen are linebackers
that disrupt the offense, sure.
- Go ahead.
We have enough time to bounce,
if you got something on
the tip of your tongue,
please feel free.
- [Attendee] One of the
things I'm really impressed
by is the VaynerX umbrella, right?
You've got different distinct businesses.
We met today different folks across those.
Gary, what's driving that structure?
As opposed.
Oh okay, it's the speed, you can move--
- That.
You know, I'm tired of
paying a big commission
on my speaking fee.
The kid who's been doing it
for nine years is becoming a grownup,
I really genuinely like him.
I'm building one mass of
communications framework,
part of communications is
humans that communicate.
We should start a speaking bureau.
That's the success.
I don't talk about Vayner Experience.
And Vayner Live.
We've, I've had two failed attempts now
at doing event marketing.
- [Attendee] He was in the hallways today.
- I know, I was with him.
I love losing.
As much as I love The Sasha Group is
as much as I love Vayner
Live and Vayner Experience
because I know the fifth
time I'm gonna get it
because live events
matter in today's world.
Definitely matters in your world,
it's a place to think about.
So like, you know?
So.
- [Ice Cream Attendee] Do
you move fast when you decide
that something's not working?
- Yes.
But, where my team thinks I move slow is
it might not manifest
in as quickly as it out,
it's because I haven't
decided that's not working.
I'm okay being down 31
nothing at half time
if I truly believe I'm gonna win 35-31.
As you can imagine,
if you've got executives,
consumers, business partners.
They're like, you're down 31 nothing.
- [Ice Cream Attendee] Right, yeah.
- You know?
And I'm like, mm-hmm.
But I was at the Monday Night Miracle.
We were down 30 to seven
with 10 minutes left, we won.
- [Attendee] Great game.
- It sure was.
I wish social media existed
so I could prove I was there
'cause every Jet fan
claims they were there,
but there was only fucking
four thousand people there.
So, you know, I think that I do,
I do, but that's a
singular decision by me.
Not my experts rallying around.
But, when my experts rally around,
and I hold the line,
and the final comes in 48 to 17,
I look at them and say, I was wrong.
So if you're gonna do it
to keep credibility with your team mates,
you have to acknowledge when you're wrong.
So yes, I do.
And sometimes that goes the other way.
You know, sometimes, I mean.
There's this story I reference a lot
of hiring somebody and literally knowing
within 24 hours of them
being in the building
that I fucked up big.
That's fun, you know.
(attendees laughing)
Yeah so, you know.
- [Attendee] We met with Clyde today--
- Yes.
- [Man In Gray Shirt] And he
really reinforced the heart,
the culture.
Who do you look for when you're hiring,
particularly your top talent?
The folks reporting to you,
the ones that are the emerging
talent in that top bucket?
- Humility.
The big one, I'm so confident
and I love people so much
that the great mistake I've
made over the last decade
which I think I'm just back
to being in your prime,
I think I'm just on the
cusp of finally fixing,
was I was attracted to
people that were insecure
because I wanted to help them.
So, the real answer is people
that are deeply confident in who they are,
which then manifests
in very good behavior.
If you're wildly confident,
you're actually extremely humble.
As I've done to know myself better,
I'm like, why am I so weird?
Like, so much conviction and confidence,
but like,
like, if you really get to the people,
like, humility is
absolutely my superpower.
And so I'm starting to look for more,
it's all emotional intelligence.
It's are you confident, are
you kind, are you capable?
And I'm doing a better and better job
of really communicating to people, like,
my big thing to people is, like, look.
Everybody is saying in
today's world what I'm saying.
So you're gonna think I'm kind of joking
and you're gonna be able to
get away with being a dick.
I'm like, I'm saving you a lot of time.
You will be fired if you're not good
to the other boys and girls.
Do you have the capability
of being the bigger girl
or guy in every situation?
Every time.
You're 100% right, yet you
still roll with empathy
and compassion and then you can come to me
and be like, Karen's a
dick-face, can we fix this?
But to them, so you don't rock the boat.
Communication capabilities.
Are you the kind of person that,
when the going gets rough, lashes out?
Don't join here.
'Cause I'm the kind of person
when the going gets rough,
I'm in my calm and
happiest and kindest state.
I'm a wartime general.
So I'm trying to
communicate those virtues.
The skill is a commodity.
Skill's a commodity.
- Here, I got a question.
So, for the past year, we grow like crazy.
It works.
- Yes, I've heard of this.
You know, we're growing hundreds
of thousands of followers.
- It's so fun to talk
about what I talk about
'cause I know it's a 100% right.
'Cause I've already lived it.
- Yeah.
- I'm never guessing.
So it makes me happy
and, like, you know this.
People don't call me on my bluff.
- Yeah.
- Like, that's what you guys actually did,
you actually just did it.
Like, tomorrow I'm putting out this deck,
the whole thing I'm
alluding to on my social,
like, gift for everybody.
We're putting out a, Jason,
how big of a deck is it?
- [Jason] 250 pages?
- Put it on 250-page deck
that we've put, like,
it probably, I don't even wanna,
it probably cost me
$100,000 to, like, make
if I looked at all the hours that went in.
Like, I don't even wanna look.
It's going to be, it's almost
like if I mapped my DNA.
What's it titled?
How to make 60, what's the file number?
- [Jason] 50 in...
- 50, it's not 50, I didn't
let them make it round.
I think it's 63 now.
It's basically how to make 63
pieces of content in a day.
But for real, like.
You know, I have that
Gary Vee content pyramid,
which was a great, great deck
and, like, everybody lost their mind?
This is, like, on some 301 level shit.
I'm so pumped for tomorrow.
Anyway, nonetheless, go ahead.
- Yeah so, we're actually not
really stuck on anything--
- Good.
- I think the answer to a
lot of it, just doing more.
We're putting it all back into place--
- So what can I answer?
- So, couple things.
You know, we made over a thousand posts,
but that was me and him.
- Yep.
- And now, it's the time
to start building kinda,
a little bit what, like,
what you got going on.
Especially, 'cause we spent
all the time in the dirt.
I'm like running through
video guides like crazy.
- Why?
What's your intuition?
But like, let's play, let's play.
'Cause take on the accountability
instead of the part
that is, like.
- [Long Haired Man] Our hiring sucks.
- Good.
This is, by the way, that
little moment is everything.
If you wanna know actually
why I think I'll buy the New York Jets,
it was that 45 seconds.
The world says, 'cause
nobody wants to work,
and I say, 'cause my hiring sucks.
And I love you for going there quickly.
Now, you start hacking.
You've got to be way more
upfront of the expectations.
Like, when I hired my team,
and Dio knows this, it's like,
you're gonna do what I did.
You're gonna eat dirt, this is terrible.
- I've got a story.
- Do you?
- Oh, yeah.
- Gimme one, gimme, I wanna hear.
- I was unpaid for eight months,
I paid $400 a month to commute to Vayner.
I got on a train from
the beach in New Jersey
and it took me two hours and 45 minutes,
door-to-door for six months.
And I was just like,
up for an expectation.
Then I got in a room with him
and he said, give me 16 more months
and you'll be exactly
where I want you to be.
And I gave him 16 more months
and like, you know,
like the first three years
of my career, pretty much.
- We used to actually do a
lot more gauntlet-type stuff
that was, 'cause we didn't have any money,
so we were like, yeah, just
work for free for weeks.
- That's exactly right.
So like, I think one
of the things you need
to think about is where I get caught too
and I say to myself is,
when you didn't have anything to offer,
it kinda worked out because
almost the expectation upfront
was a better communication
where you have a little fluff
now, you can get caught.
This is so, like, cliche.
I think you have to, to your point,
I think you should almost
probably make a video
that's like funny and cool and on-brand,
but like completely communicates
if you wanna do video for us, like,
this is what it's about.
You gotta make the promise more upfront.
It's on us.
I used to fire people and
even during Nick's time,
he knows this.
There's people here that I did
so well by who don't like me
because I didn't communicate well enough
that they weren't doing a good job
so they were flabbergasted
when they got fired.
And that's the post game version
of where you guys gotta be in the pregame,
you need to over-communicate expectation.
Like, over-communicate.
You know, and not do the,
we walk 15 feet in snow for four miles,
like that thing we all do, like, I fuck,
like these kids don't,
like even your kids and you're like,
these kids don't wanna work, you know?
Like, that's not the actual truth.
It's that you painted the wrong picture.
- Yeah, I can see that.
And so, another thing we have is,
so we have, like, a worldwide brand
and there's like diehards who would, like,
move out to Atlanta in two seconds--
- I believe that, I believe that.
- I have a slight problem,
'cause we've had a situation.
People coming in and
then, once you let 'em go,
then you're like, they
got an apartment lease.
We uprooted them, we feel really--
- That's fair, that's fair.
- And it makes me scared
to, like, fish out the--
- That's fair, that's fair.
There's two ways to handle that.
One, you over-communicate that upfront.
Two, you do what I do which is
you give egregious severances
to make yourself feel better.
(laughing)
- [Long Haired Man] That's
what we have done, thankfully.
- We did something at
Vayner where I was, like,
trying to let the company do its thing
and they fired somebody
and I fucking hated the way they did it.
I literally fucking
PayPal-ed the guy a ton
of my own personal money.
And then I told them and
they were fucking pissed,
HR and finance.
And I was like, cool.
Why don't you start paying
attention to how I want it?
Because every time I watch you guys do it,
I'm gonna do this.
- [Long Haired Man] Yeah, that's crazy.
- It is a little crazy, I like that story.
(attendees laughing)
My admins lost their mind.
They're like, this guy's on some,
'cause they see everything.
They're like, all right,
this guy's playing with,
like, you know.
It's one of those, like,
when you think you've seen
everything and they're like,
what is this guy doing?
I'm making a fucking
point is what I'm doing.
- And one other thing--
- Yeah.
Where are you at it with TikTok?
- [Long Haired Man]
One viral video so far.
- How much are you posting?
- [Long Haired Man] Everyday.
- How much?
One? More.
Listen to me.
Because you guys have already
won on this, four a day.
All you're doing, last time, a year ago,
was buying up under-priced real estate.
And you were doing that on Instagram
when it was already four or
five years into the knowledge
that Beverly Hills or Malibu
or Manhattan was gonna be good.
You just bought Manhattan
in 1954 instead of 1898.
TikTok is 1898.
- [Long Haired Man] I'm trying.
- Good, try more.
(laughing)
I mean it because we can't
get that moment back.
You can't buy Facebook pre-IPO back.
You can buy it when it
was $20 on Wall Street,
but that was already not
three dollars, like I got it.
- And we're feeling it right now too,
you could see how--
- [Long Haired Man] It's crazy.
- Dude, I'm telling you
I know what I'm talking.
This is the one thing
that will keep me relevant
'til the day I die.
I understand under-priced
organic attention
of the consumers of
the world wildly better
than most people on earth.
I keep saying it, loud.
And LinkedIn, for multiple, like.
Like, you gotta post on
LinkedIn four times a day.
It'll work.
These, it's free reach.
I don't know what else to say.
There's nothing more, I didn't,
this is actually unbelievable timing.
I had Brandon, who runs Wine Library.
So we have this wine
texting, it's really working.
And so I'll say I feel very confident
on digital capabilities to grow the list.
But I'm like, you know,
I'm always checking myself.
I'm like, I wonder what's going
on with traditional costs.
New York Times was one
of the biggest ways I
built my dad's business.
National New York Times' ads.
On Wednesday, is today Wednesday?
- Yep.
- Yep, on Wednesdays
in the dining section.
National dining section,
full-page ad, Wine Library, huge.
I'm like, okay, that used to
be $42,000 for a full-page ad.
I bet you it's like $20,000.
I wonder if I should run one,
just to really have any feel whatsoever
to how print does in 2020.
I'm like, Brandon, call the Times,
find out how much it costs.
He calls me back yesterday, he's like,
hey, got the pricing, I'm like,
all right, I was like excited,
I was like, how much is it?
He's like, 46 thousand.
I like literally,
I'm like in Chicago the
last two days ago, I'm like.
Wait a minute, it's gone up 10%?
He's like, yeah.
Oh, these fuckers.
How the fuck is full-page print
ad up 10% in cost from 1998?
When there was no Internet
to have your attention?
Anyway, nonetheless.
TikTok, four times a day.
It will be--
- [Long Haired Man] We're
doing events, by the way.
- Love, yeah, I mean that's--
- [Partner] I was going to
ask you what you think of it
'cause it's crazy--
- I'm obsessed.
- [TikTok Attendee] Two,
three hundred people come out
and they are diehards, like, love us.
- Yeah, more.
- [TikTok Attendee]
You think they're good?
- Yeah, I do.
I love real life, I love real life.
I'll give you another one.
You wanna really get value out of events?
Spend the extra money
to do something crazy
that everybody wants to take a photo with.
- Cool.
- That's a good idea.
- You see where I'm going?
- Yeah.
- Spend like an extra,
now it's break even,
charge a little more
and then buy a $4,000,
like, 800-foot foot.
- [Long Haired Man] I mean,
we're okay with even
losing money on these.
- I bet you, 'cause it's
branding, you're smart.
So like, the number one thing
that I love about real life
is the Instagram photo.
'Cause now you're taking 300 people
and they're building you the awareness
up to six thousand people.
And if you give them the ammo
for the ridiculous photo, you win.
- [Long Haired Man] I love that.
- I wouldn't even think of that.
- Well that's why you keep coming back.
- Yeah, exactly.
- [Attendee] So if, right now
I'm doing this as like a--
- Side hustle?
- Side hustle.
Yeah, so if I'm trying to,
I asked these guys some feedback on,
if I don't necessarily wanna be a brand,
is it better to create, like,
a company brand or create
some kind of a character?
- Did you wanna, real quick,
did you wanna sneak anything
out since you're leaving?
- [Man Leaving] That was
my biggest question, yeah.
- Did it hit? (snapping)
- [Man Leaving] Unbelievably,
which is part of why I gotta go.
- So do me a favor, do me a
favor, do me favor on that.
Like,
it, one of the problem,
I'm very good at doing what comes natural
to me at a 40,
not a 10.
But I was also very good at
what didn't come natural to me
to do at a zero.
That's why I failed school.
Like, I've come to learn I
was more than smart enough
to probably get Cs, but I got Fs.
I was really good
at completely punting
something I wasn't good at.
The proudest thing that ever happened
in my life at this point,
from a personal standpoint,
forget about kids and stuff like that,
was when I recognized at 38 and a half
that I needed to get
serious about my health.
The fact that I then turned that into not
what I first thought in the plane,
which is at 40, I'll get serious.
On my 40th birthday, I'll start.
And then, within two hours of that flight,
started literally the next day,
is kinda what of want
to inspire you to do,
which is, the only way
that this good moment means anything is
if you actually put it
directly into practice.
(snapping) Even though
it doesn't come natural.
You know, 'cause you're
doing what comes natural,
so give that some thought,
like, really push.
Whatever tricks you to do it, you know?
- [Man Leaving] Right now.
- Good, awesome.
- [Attendee] Good seeing you, man.
- [Man Leaving] Likewise.
Thanks, appreciate it.
- [Ice Cream Attendee]
Thanks, nice to meet you.
- [Man Leaving] Appreciate it.
- I hope you enjoy the rest of the day.
- [Man Leaving] Absolutely, thank you.
- If you don't wanna be
the personal brand, right?
- [Man] Right.
I'm a little eliminated right now.
- Of course.
What, the question is
what brand do you build?
Is that what you're asking?
- [Man] Yeah, I'm just curious, is,
do I start branding like as a company
or, I've thought about it,
just kinda creating
some kind of character.
- What kinda character?
Talk, I like it, what kinda character?
- [Man] You know, like a
Western type character.
- Like you acting as it,
animation, hiring somebody?
- [Man] A person or animation, yeah.
- Animation, I love 'cause
Mickey Mouse is a lot easier
to control than Susan Sarandon.
You know what I mean?
- [Attendee] Yeah.
- So I'm a big fan of
animation, like a big one.
And I actually think it's one
of the big white spaces in
social marketing right now.
Like, I'm probably gonna create
a augmented reality character
that's gonna start showing
up in all my content,
it's a big conversation
we're having right now.
And then he'll be where,
just like he wears Goosebumps,
he'll be wearing, like, my virtual dog
that always barks when
people do dumb shit.
And then everybody's gonna think it's cool
and I'm gonna sell stickers
and plush toys and bark-y bark.
- [Man] And then, like, to
piggyback off their question,
if I was gonna do some
kind of an event evening,
just 'cause, you know, I would want it--
- Talk to me where we're at
right now in the side hustle.
You've made stuff?
- Yeah, stuff is in production currently.
But we have a--
- And who's we?
A theoretical we or you have partners?
- [Man] No, I haven't.
It's my wife and I and
then I've hired somebody
to help me kinda navigate
the fashion industry
as a side hustle.
And she has a lot of experience
with this type of fabrics,
this type of stuff,
design and everything.
- Awesome.
- [Man] So, just trying to, like--
- Yeah, get off the ground, yeah.
I'm gonna make this very simple.
Your job is so simple
and extremely hard.
You have to make people aware of it,
and compel them to buy it.
Right?
By, you're gonna sell
it on your own website?
- [Attendee] Yeah.
- So, right away, that has extra friction
that a lotta people right
now don't want, right?
Because, this is why
Amazon and other places,
like, people don't wanna put
their credit card into shit.
It's like, like even though
they have automatic fill-out,
like, people don't understand
how powerful convenience is.
It's why the Apple credit card thing
is really interesting to me.
Like, it's just friction.
Like, I would be more
likely to buy your product
if I could just, like,
not fill out anything
and that's, like, where
this is all going, right?
So anyway, nonetheless.
You have to build brand.
The reason I get obsessed
with LinkedIn and TikTok is
you don't have unlimited funds,
so you need to be most efficient.
There's two ways to do it.
One, you win on art or
you win on math, right?
Math is, you had the kinda background,
I'm making up this scenario.
You come from financial services,
so you're grounded in math
and you become incredible
at Facebook and Instagram,
arbitrage and your CAC is under your LTV
and you're just crushing it.
You're one of those guys, right?
It doesn't even matter about
that much about the marketing,
it's just that you're so
good at buying the ads
and it's converting so well
and you're not under
water and you're happy.
Or, you're in the art stuff.
Which is, like, you understand
how to make the creative
that actually gets people.
Like Dollar Shave Club was an
execution of art, not of math.
Even though it was a classic DTC brand
that is completely built on
normally being reliant on math.
So, this is why I think
people will forever follow me.
'Cause if the keep just
doing what I'm doing
and layer their own self-awareness on it
to know which part they can and can't do,
it's great that you know that, like,
you've decided for yourself,
maybe because your other
business, or your job,
or maybe just who you are as a human,
I don't wanna be the front.
The good news is that is
not a requirement at all.
There are far more brands
that are winning than personal brands.
So it's more common for that.
I think, influencer
marketing is a beast for you.
Like, I don't think people understand
how apparel really works, like,
you're one person deciding to wear it away
from doing more for your business
than nine thousand other executions.
So I think that's a very
heavy place to focus on,
but a lot of the rest of
what 4Ds was about has
laid out for you the game.
- [Attendee] Happy birthday, Gary.
- Thank you, bro.
- [Attendee] And thank you for your staff,
I was scheduled twice in
L.A. so Nick and RG made it.
- Awesome, thank you.
- [Attendee] So let's say you have
to purchase a Wine Library today
and Sasha had run it old school way--
- Yes.
- [Attendee] For 40 years.
- [Man] And you purchase it today.
- Yes.
- [Attendee] What would
you do to get the word out?
- That there's new ownership?
- [Attendee] Not necessarily.
- Understood.
Word out for acquiring talent internally
or external clients?
- [Attendee] External clients.
- Keep going, understood.
- [Attendee] And in California.
- Yep.
And I assume the business,
based on 40 years,
why you brought up Sasha
is, and at that level,
has strictly been a hardcore grinding,
word-of-mouth business for 40 years.
- [Attendee] Exactly.
- Understood.
- [Attendee] That was hardcore grinding.
Yeah, the showroom knows, exactly.
- That's how 40 years and
three million looks like.
- [Attendee] Yeah, yeah.
- That's what I do for a
living, I understand, okay?
- [Attendee] We have a showroom presence
in northern California, it
doesn't work everywhere,
but in northern California, it does work.
- What do you think your value prop is?
- [Attendee] In northern California
or California in general?
- California in general.
- [Attendee] California in general,
next day ground service?
- Okay.
- [Attendee] To anywhere
in California and--
- But I assume everybody in
California can do that too.
- [Attendee] Next day ground, no.
- Why?
- [Attendee] 'Cause they're not in,
most of their head office,
they're moving out of California
because just the cost of
doing business in California.
- Yeah, fuck California.
- [Attendee] Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- [Attendee] So, and then, face-to-face,
we actually see a face-to-face,
you can call us from a
customer service side-point.
You can actually reach a
customer service person directly,
right away and then also face-to-face,
you can actually see your rep.
- Do a couple things.
I would start a podcast around supplies.
And I'm not kidding.
I'm a big buyer of very
narrow, very small,
very niche podcasts
and I would invite the runners
of the companies to be guests
to talk about their careers.
I'm not kidding.
And I would be the host of the show
and I would invite the
executives on the show
to talk about life.
By doing that, you become, you
gain the leverage on brand,
of becoming the place of authority
and all you're doing is interviewing
your actual potential customers
and making them feel famous.
Which then builds awareness.
If you emailed the 900 clients
that you know who you're
trying to get, right?
- [Attendee] Correct.
- Correct, if you emailed them and said,
hey, it's me, I want your
business, that's one thing.
If you emailed them and said,
hey, I have something called the show,
and I noticed that you've been
the seven-year head at Canon.
You know--
- [Attendee] We sold to Canon, actually.
- Amazing.
So, we'd love to have you on
the show to talk about life.
Nerd culture, what's
going on in the industry,
your personal career.
You'll never get anybody
to reply on the first one.
You'll get half of them to
reply on the second one.
I would do that.
I would then do what I do
with DailyVee and my podcast.
I would have that interview,
then I would cut it up in
a post-production world,
and I would run ads on
LinkedIn of snippets
from other people for them to see it.
- [Attendee] Yeah, 'cause LinkedIn is huge
in terms of--
- No, LinkedIn's your world.
You run LinkedIn ads against employees
and engineers of the
companies your trying to reach
with the content being something smart
that one of the people
said on your show coming
from the account that
is you or your business.
Game over, you build a business.
- [Attendee] So you run LinkedIn ads
against prospective--
- Correct.
- Companies.
- With content, not commercials.
With CNBC content,
not infomercial, buy my
program content, got it?
- [Attendee] So no call to action?
- No call to action.
- [Attendee] Yeah, 'cause we just need--
- 'Cause everything else he's
doing is a sales organization.
He's a sales organization.
Everything he has in place
is a sales organization.
Whatever he has is sales.
This is building brand.
- [Attendee] Once we get face-to-face,
we close probably 75% of the time.
- I would argue,
VaynerMedia's the fastest
growing revenue agency
in the world.
I would argue that we're
in the bottom one percent
of worst new business processes.
We legitimately don't know
how to do new business.
That's how much top of
the funnel brand we have
that just, people hand us business.
The companies in the
world that only do RFPs
and only have procurement,
literally hand us the business.
Because a top of the funnel brand.
And then the best part, true word of mouth
and people that have
actually worked with us.
Steak and sizzle.
Only two things are gonna be left.
The actual product and
the variable within it,
and the ability to communicate.
And the ability
to communicate is more
powerful than a product,
'cause oftentimes the product
has already been told you
of its quality based on the communication.
You've been told.
You've been told this is the best burger.
You've been told this is the best handbag.
Why is this handbag $8,000?
It's the best, really?
Because if I take that burka off its name
and gave you the same
thing, it's 800 bucks.
Brand.
- [Attendee] A lot of the
similar process you just did
of diagnosing and then running through it,
I'd love to maybe,
so the company's called
Revature, a Sasha client.
We, you know,
last year, about 100,000 leads
converted to 2,000 starts,
so the revenue generation
happens with this next starts.
- Yep.
- [Attendee] And, over the
lifetime of that student,
we get about $100,000, so
we wanna get those starts.
Our business challenge today is--
- Have you spoken to those 98,000 people?
- [Attendee] In what way?
- Have you called them and asked
them why they didn't do it?
- [Attendee] We've done a lead conversion
failure study--
- But it's 100,000 to 2,000, right?
- [Man] Yeah, so a 2% conversion rate--
- Yeah, understood.
How many of the 98,000
have you actually had a conversation with?
What's your gut tell you?
- [Man] Probably--
- For real, for real,
don't, like, give it to me.
- [Attendee] 60% contact rate,
so there's been at least
one contact over the phone.
- But like, no, no.
Asking them why they, not--
- [Attendee] Oh, okay, so those.
- Post-game.
- [Attendee] Of those 24,000,
we know they didn't convert
because of one or two issues, yeah.
Because we have training
locations across the country
and they didn't wanna relocate.
So relocation is the number one reason.
- Stop running ads that
go into those regions.
- [Attendee] Into those regions.
- That's, start point number one, right?
- [Attendee] Yeah, yeah.
- How are you guys
acquiring leads, Facebook?
- [Attendee] And through job boards.
- Understood.
- [Attendee] So Indeed--
- Yep, yep, yep.
- [Attendee] All the classic job boards.
We don't do Google or Facebook today.
- Really?
- Which is a reason why--
- It's great, I'm glad, I'm glad.
Because it's great,
those are great lead gens
'cause it's intent-based.
But if we can focus on being regional
with our lead gen from a Google
and Facebook environment,
it gets real good.
- [Attendee] Yeah, yeah.
So, one thing is to stop in those regions
where we just don't get much back.
- If you can, I'm not familiar enough
with the job boards
regionality capabilities.
- [Attendee] Yeah, and
part of the struggle trying
to figure out is, you know,
when you're in an operation, you know,
your job is to testing
and learning all the time,
but pulling back from job boards,
'cause it works so well,
it's fueled our growth.
- Right, now you're talking
about why everybody goes out of business.
The number one reason people go out
of business is they're
romantic about the thing
that got them there.
Yep, I understand that.
- [Attendee] Yeah.
And then on building the
brand, this podcast thing.
- It's real for you.
- [Attendee] Because you
could just market to--
- If every, you know how everybody's like,
oh, my company's got a purpose
and we're doing things for,
like, you know how everybody,
that's, you know,
now we've gotta all be
woke and amazing people,
so every fucking startup is like,
we give back a dollar to the rainforest
or we really give a fuck
about snails in Portugal
or like, we care about
people with hangnails.
Like, everyone's gotta have something.
I actually think the
right way to do that is
to actually have a content
arm of every business
that acts like a complete
church and state editorial,
I predict that in 15 years,
every single business will
have an editor-in-chief
who cannot be touched by anybody.
If you had a content
arm that had no intent
of it being the top of the, my friends,
the reason I believe I win is
'cause when I make content,
there is absolutely no thought
of how it trickles down to these moments.
That's the punchline.
- [Attendee] Not intentional
in the performance
of the funnel, it's just content.
- I have a former employee
who tweeted out yesterday
that there is no such
thing as free content.
And somebody jumped in and like,
'cause this person's always
giving me good accolades
that I've helped them.
And they're like, what about Gary Vee?
And this person was like, even him.
And I laughed.
I was like, he didn't hang out long enough
to actually get it.
- [Attendee] Yeah.
- Of course there's
something that happens,
but it's, but I know who I am as a human.
I know when I make a video,
I know what's happening.
People don't understand that
that's actually the punchline.
If you can stay disciplined
and actually try to
bring entertainment value
and information value to every employee,
you'll get business
because people are wanna be
on your fuckin' podcast after a year.
Mark my words.
Yours has more.
You know, more, like
there's a lot more shows
for, like, going into the
workplace, HR, millennial workers.
Now you're in the game of being best.
You have to do what these
guys did on Instagram.
Instagram was at scale a year ago.
Enough scale that if them
getting all these results,
they were good at it.
Now I'm trying to get
them to get what he has,
which is like TikTok, you
don't have to be good at it.
Just go hard, yeah, 'cause
there's more of a buy there.
He's gonna win just on
actually creating it.
He only needs 47 people
listening to his podcast
for it to change his business.
It's cool, this is why
I love B2B marketing.
He legitimately, this is no joke,
'cause you guys are in
the see business like me,
like, he actually needs the fuckin',
400 people actively listening for it
to double his business overnight.
- [Attendee] I actually need 10 clients,
I could double my business--
- I'm aware.
- [Attendee] No, seriously.
- And it works for all of us, even B2C.
Like, you could start the ice cream show.
- [Ice Cream Attendee] I
was thinking about that,
so after I bought out my partner,
I just had to change brand--
- Sure.
- Packaging and, you know.
- You gotta do the things that you, yeah.
You gotta do the things you wanted
to do all along, I get it.
- And then there's also a
fear factor to it, we are,
I didn't wanna do anything
and make mistakes.
So it's kind of surprising to me
that we're as good as we
are without any brand.
You know, without the brand
that built up the brand.
- Is it poss, this is exciting to ask,
is it just a great product?
- It's, I mean--
- I know, it's your baby, I get it.
- I do think it's a really, really--
- That happens, you know, that happens.
- I really, no, but it's not,
it's not saying that that's great.
- I get it, I get it.
- I'm saying that it's, you know,
so now I'm at the point now
where I have to raise the brand awareness.
We are going into e-commerce,
I don't wanna start it unless, you know,
we have the sales going there.
So I, you know, I'm sort
of starting at square one.
- Yeah, you are.
- Yeah.
- That's great.
- Is it?
(laughing) I don't know--
- You know why it's great?
You have no choice.
- Right.
But like, for example, like TikTok.
I know it's a younger audience.
- Yes.
- That's not necessarily the
people that are, you know,
it's the moms, it's the, you know.
- Well let's talk about a couple things.
One thing that you should know is
that teenage girls influence mom decisions
of buying products in the home
at a level that we've never seen.
So one viral video.
So let's talk about LaCroix.
LaCroix sparkling water
was completely a phenomenon
of Instagram girls, which
then led to the moms.
I would argue the best thing
that can happen to you
is virality in TikTok,
not mom-blogger.
- [Ice Cream Attendee] But as
far as creating that content,
does that all come from,
I mean, I sort of--
- You the human or you the executive
who empowers something to
happen for the brand to do it?
- [Ice Cream Attendee] I
guess, me the executive.
- Yeah, yes, it does, that's right.
You have to be educated
enough to make the right hire.
This is what I always yell
out in my conferences.
You know, I'll do my talk,
there's always this great moment
when I'm in that kind
of talk where I'm like,
I get the whole conservative crew
where people that haven't
done it, like super on-board.
And then I'm like, then
I switch it on them.
Like, but now I know what you're thinking.
Now that I've got you
over the last 20 minutes,
you're about to hire your niece.
You're about to hire
the cliche 23 year old
from school 'cause you think they get it.
If you don't have the
ability to judge that person,
you're vulnerable.
My favorite thing is I
can do every job here.
I can't do it well.
Like, I can't do any of
the jobs at Vayner well.
But I know them all.
I can definitely judge it.
And that's super important
when you own a business.
Yes, for sure.
- [Ice Cream Attendee] So if I'm trying
to find somebody to post on TikTok,
let's say, to create content for TikTok--
- Let me give you a real
insight that I used to,
I only said it once publicly,
I'm gonna say it again now,
I'm gonna say it a lot more.
I really, really, really
want you to download TikTok.
- [Ice Cream Attendee] I do.
- Great, and I really,
really, really want you
to spend five full hours
over the next 30 days,
next 60 days, of just consuming it.
You will be blown away by how
that little exercise will make
you far more knowledgeable.
You'll just have context.
- [Ice Cream Attendee] Yeah.
- You're like, why are
they all doing that dance?
First you're gonna say, man.
God, what's society do we live in
where every 11 year old talks
about sex a lot more than I ever thought.
Like, we start doing all those things,
but like, you'll learn.
You'll have a much better shot
at making a judgment, but yes.
- [Ice Cream Attendee]
No, but as far as like,
then who do you, you're
trying to hire somebody that
to help create that content,
that understands TikTok, so
aren't they the 17 year olds?
- I'm 43.
- [Dio] Almost 44.
- Notice how I've blurb-ed it, I said 44,
now fuck it, I got a couple more hours.
- [Ice Cream Attendee] So
maybe that's the misconception
on my part--
- It's the biggest
misconception of all time.
Like, we do such typecasting.
I hate that, like, people
that understand a Latino
consumer don't have to be Latino
and vice versa.
There's plenty of Latinos that
understand Caucasian mindset.
You need somebody who's capable
and that doesn't mean a 17 year old.
To your point, it's far more
likely that it is right now.
But what I love about the five hours is,
I mean, you, I gotta tell you.
It's so fun, life.
Like, if you came back,
if I got an email from you in nine months
and it said you will not believe this.
Before I started reading it, I'm like,
she's the one making the TikTok.
Like, you just never know.
I don't know what else to say.
This thesis is what
brought me to Gary Vee,
who's 34 years old before I made content.
I was running a retail store.
I didn't think I was a personality,
I didn't move to L.A. and
wait tables to be on TV.
You don't know until,
you might be the person.
You just might.
It seems foreign as shit,
but after you get five hours
of it and you're like huh.
And just kinda make one, like.
It's the cliche story.
You're like sitting there,
you're thinking back to this exact moment,
you're like, what do I have to lose?
We have no followers anyway.
You do some sort of funny thing with the,
there's a huge trend
where people pour soda
or beverages into a cup
against this one song
until it overflows.
You might just be like,
I'm gonna do that with our ice cream.
Sure enough,
this is why TikTok's special.
You do that on YouTube, Twitter,
Facebook, or Instagram, nothing happens.
But because there's free
organic views on TikTok,
you do that, and the
right TikTok-er sees it
and does their own version of it,
and you wake up in a week and you're like,
Gary is a fucking genius.
- [TikTok Attendee] Yeah, that's a real,
that's completely the way TikTok.
Like literally, so Drew
makes awesome content.
I posted, I was at Costco with a chick,
like chickens coming out of the oven,
it got 400,000 likes.
It's no joke.
- [Drew] And this is like the most random.
- [Attendee] (laughing) It's so stupid.
- [Drew] Pull it up, let me pull it up.
- [Long Haired Man] It's literally that--
- [Ice Cream Attendee] My
daughter keeps showing the one
of the woman that tests
kombucha and I'm like--
- Oh, Kombucha Girl?
She's a monster.
- [Ice Cream Attendee] Kombucha Girl,
she's all over the place.
- 400,000 likes.
I was just at Costco.
I was like, what?
Like it's literally that crazy.
- [Long Haired Man] But when
it's good content, it gets--
- And, all those chickens are on branded.
If you did that with your ice cream,
like that visual, that much awareness.
This is how it works.
You know, when that Texas kid goes
to an H-E-B after you get distribution,
and they're like pissed that they're there
with their mom at the supermarket,
'cause after softball practice.
But they saw that TikTok and
they, mom, mom, get that.
That's real life.
All my friends who were making fun of me
about my TikTok propaganda,
all have gotten really quiet
because if they've been with
me in the last three weeks,
they've watched an eight
year old run up to me
and lose their mind and take a selfie.
And every time, they
look at me like, TikTok.
- [Drew] Gary, do you worry
about the perfect demo
coming out of TikTok?
'Cause it's kinda all over the web,
do you just say fuck it and go for it all?
- I'm trying to reach
every person on earth.
Right?
So I don't.
The demo is somebody who's alive.
You know?
- [Drew] Also, do we wanna
reach everybody's that's alive?
- Of course you do.
They'll self-select out of your shit.
- [Drew] That's true.
- You know how many people
hate me 'cause I curse?
Doesn't mean I'm not trying to get 'em.
- [Attendee] Building a personal brand--
- Yes.
- [Attendee] Assuming baseline.
- Yep.
- [Attendee] What do you recommend?
- Self-awareness of how you
best enjoy communicating
and that allows you to
make the most content.
Written word, audio, or video.
Starts there.
- [Attendee] And then once
you've done that self-assessment,
let's say it's written--
- Great.
- And video.
- Yep, then you make at scale.
- [Attendee] And if, yeah.
And if you're not able to
sign up for VaynerTalent.
- You do it on your phone.
- [Attendee] Just do it on your phone?
- [Drew] That's what I do everyday.
- Yep.
- [Attendee] Everyday
doing phone and post it?
- I did it for eight years.
I didn't have a single person on my team.
- [Attendee] And you posted?
So you just wake up every
morning and do a video.
- Just wrote tweets on Twitter.
- [Attendee] Just put it on Twitter and?
- I had a flip cam.
Remember those things?
Just like set it up and you're like.
All starts the same way, right?
It's all the same shit, right?
Oh, we don't have the amps and the guitars
to be like you guys.
I'm like, they didn't either.
They were a garage band,
they had a shitty thing
the bought at a garage sale
and went to guitar store.
Oh, we don't have the, I can't
be like Steven Spielberg.
Steven Spielberg had a
shitty fucking camera
and made background movies,
like it's all the same shit.
You don't need an Equinox
membership to work out.
You can go outside and,
Dio does that kinda,
jump on fucking buildings
or something, I don't know.
You know.
Everybody uses an excuse.
If you can write, you've won.
Everything on your phone.
Go write your point of view
on a current job market to millennials
on LinkedIn right now as
a blog post, right now.
Actually, you know what?
I wanna add that.
I wanna add that to 4Ds.
I wanna add to 4Ds, a
forced moment of 15 minutes
for people to actually
make a piece of content.
- [Dio] Great.
- On the spot.
- [Drew] That's a good idea.
- Especially on the two
that are organic reach.
LinkedIn and TikTok.
I like that.
- [Attendee] How much time do you spend
doing personal content
development out of your...
- What'd ya think?
You two, what cha got?
- [Jason] What was the question?
- How much time do I spend?
- [Jason] On a daily basis?
- Yeah.
- [Attendee] Developing
his own personal content.
- [Jason] An hour, 30 minutes, maybe less.
- [Attendee] You do it
like first thing in--
- I write everything.
Every single tweet you see, I wrote that.
Every single piece of copy.
All the written words under
an Instagram post, that's me.
I post every single Instagram post.
- [Jason] I would say maximum 40 minutes.
- [Attendee] Do you have a
habit, do you do it mornings?
- But think about that.
Think about the fact
that I'm at, think about.
Yeah, just think about 40.
Yeah, just think about 40 minutes, though.
Like, there's not a.
Yeah, like nobody's, no
executive's doing that.
It is the single most
important thing in the world.
Communication's the only thing left.
Everything else is getting commoditized.
- [Attendees] How about events?
You talked about events for them.
- I think you start with the podcast,
'cause it gives you
permission to do events.
Once you have 400 listeners,
when you promote your
own event on the podcast,
and then 12 people RSVP,
you're like, holy shit,
people are listening.
Start with the podcast.
Do that, it'll work.
Put that flag in the ground first.
Cold, email.
You know how fun it's gonna be
to fly home and cold email the 50 people
that you dream wish that knew who,
you wish that they knew who you are
and now the email says, I'd
love to have you on our podcast.
You're gonna get yeses.
It's crazy.
- [Drew] We did that, it works.
- [Long Haired Man] Even just DMs
on Instagram worked good for us.
- Yeah, 'cause that's more your world.
His version of that is
LinkedIn messages for sure.
Yeah, all right.
- [Jason] Do a quick group photo.
- [Gary] Yeah.
(rustling)